fratello è non va bene che ti mangi tuoi
occhi non solo è un cane cinese e pur
ubriaco volevo farvi una domanda ragazzi
ma secondo voi quanto può essere [ __ ]
questa galli quanto può esservi casa
gallina tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj da oggi siamo
tornati su cic è uscita ragazzi la
versione quasi ufficiale una new orleans
banana game bello del sì c'è anche la
c'è anche l'adventure truck e tipo
minecraft ma veramente
ma perché sembra un alieno va bè ragazzi
per chi oddio
certo la legge della fisica presa e
violentata in questo istante in
questione tipo un incrocio tra minecraft
e sport che sarebbe quello dove crei gli
alieni perché anche qua puoi creare cosa
e chi poi tipo questo ma c'è una gallina
intera dentro nuovo dentro le uova trova
le galline a pezzi come le sorprese kim
creare dimostri bisogna fare questa
cupola e poi aggiungere i pezzi tipo
come cazzo si fa
posso anche volare mi hanno dimenticato
i suoi con ottimi anno devo fare o che
in ordine bello ragazzi sto
letteralmente sto costruendo una gallina
è una cosa che non si vede spesso ne per
carità di dio
manca la cresta che sarebbe questo a
contatto con le mani un figo e poi manca
l'altra l'ace ragazzi ma che il cazzo di
gallina e fatevi mettere quest'occhio da
qualche parte ma ecco vivi brutto stragi
come si fa dalla vita a sud efficiente
ma è povero cristo non c'è un occhio
proviamo ad uscire giusto per vedere se
si crea ciao zia lavorò per carità di
dio non voglia disturbarti quinto posto
ha detto di sì ragazzi perdonami dio per
aver fatto questa cosa non volevo lo so
che non puoi vedere per l'amor di dio
non si fanno queste cose ciò che non
puoi vedere perché non ti ho fatto gli
occhi però stai andando all'indietro e
soprattutto 6 andando in mare morirà da
solo affogata la pazienza 6 un arancino
e tipo quelli arancini che fanno in
sicilia fantastico sono un po più march
quindi dicono prova beh non ci credo che
ho trovato gli amici aspettano suo gatti
dei ragazzi questo è più carina di
quella di prima l'unico problema è che
c'è st motta di andare in giro con una
gamba sola che ancora non l'ho capito
prova vede comunque più bella che ho
fatto io no a dio ci sta affogando e
cazzo fai ragazzi vedo dell'arci una
balestra sono delle robe c'è una
palestra che si sta muovendo verso di me
no no non mi mettere di icona della
gallina perché quella zio non è una
[ __ ] gallina credit e calabrò devo
dirtelo posso farti una domanda chi
cazzo sei posso cavalcarla quindi se
rimango qua sopra si incazza
non si incazza si incazza invece vi
abbiamo lega veloce sì ce l'ha fatta e
non fai qui la stanza ma è prodotta
cogliano non ci ha fatto l'uovo
ecco da dove nascono 441 distrutto uno
prima e l'ho buttato direttamente in
acqua è morto sei contenta cipro stai
calma stai calma non ho fatto niente
posso rompere chiudi ti incazzi non si è
incazzata anno se incassata mi sta
seguendo non attenta però sei scema
l'hai fatto fuori più luogo sei stupido
è chi cazzo fai giochiamo a calcio
bailado gli importava doni in porta
eccole qua ho trovato allora le porte e
questa è tira da usare la devi usare
luogo è rimasta incastrata capitalista
sono questo che ci hanno la criniera
come leoni ma sembrano cavalli e hanno
la coda la giraffa sono dei cavalloni
giraffe la cosa più romantica che io
abbia mai visto in un videogame andando
a fare il bagno insieme a quanto possono
essere teneri
[Musica]
però a fare una partita in creative solo
per capire con me perché siccome quando
l'ho giocato io non era così aggiornato
ok perché ha accettato tutte le cose
fantastico quindi io posso creare gli
animali fatti strani bocca da tarantola
meno male che hanno inventato un gioco
dove poi farei e le tarantole sono
contento adesso ti fatte vedere come se
fuori stracazzo che io sono una persona
incazzata non ho capito perché allora
fanno strada rantola che non ho capito
il corpo e questo giusto bello bello
verrà me una cosa meravigliosa ragazzi
magari davanti alla bocca no perché ci
dovrei mettere la bocca che esattamente
che schifo siccome non c'è un'altra
gamba facciamoli lo zoccolo di cavallo
che è leggermente grosso sforzo al
colore cavallo ovvero le sì ma sul serio
problema va ragazzi proviamo a fare un
qualcosa di più
non lo so più carino ma che non è che ci
voglia molto e per carità di dio
facciamo un cane e il cane possiamo fare
i cani ragazzi facciamo
proviamoci ragazzi non mi prometto
niente però voluto da cane o bello ma le
lega in realtà ragazzi questo è un
problema che anche mia nonna ogni tanto
quando mangia le salta la dentiera ti
capisco credimi non sei solo ma chi ha
fatto il suo gioco lo sa come è fatto un
cane verdini non fartelo cadere per
l'amor di dio perfetto no no cazzo a
kandy cinese finto di che cazzo comune
mi cadono i pezzi e mandava quella il
tuo occhio nudo le imagna fratello è non
va bene che ti mangi tuoi occhi non solo
è un cane cinese e pur ubriaco
posso farti una carezza incazzi ragazzi
facciamo una petizione
se avessi la trocchio sarebbe abbastanza
normale questa cosa ti regalo questo
hamburger da regalo tutto tuo
non ti mangia tranquillo adesso siamo
amici perché ti ho dato un hamburger sei
mio amico no devi essere che cazzo fai
mi sta ingrossando ragazzi che lo sta
facendo e davide disse golia crepa come
fece hercules ve lo ricordate ragazzi il
campione di hercules quando alcune se
taglia le teste al tipo a quel coso lì
enorme ecco lo fa la stessa cosa ragazzi
se riesco e parlammo video non è
esattamente andata così bene alcune
cucine non ti presento fa vj l'unica
persona al mondo a morire in modalità
creative line shot la fionda dato si sta
suicidando in mare non ho figli o l'ho
preso ci ho messo un anno e mezzo dove
vai è scemo ma cos'è sta roba ma mamma
che schifo di tiro ogni volta mamma mia
sono un hercules un po moderno sono nè
alcol e scuola fionda che è già qualcosa
per l'amor di dio sa se ci vogliono per
uccidere una giraffa
non lo sapremo mai perché se l'è data a
gambe però la kodak e giusta vendeva non
è più belle polipo che voi abbiate mai
visto quanto quanto è bello ma fatemi
vedere se vive ragazzi lo adoro vi prego
qualcuno ditemi che lo vendono nei
supermercati sto coso lo voglio si porta
a spasso la come contento di portarsi a
spasso l'uomo
[Musica]
ama mi ama mi ama cosa stai facendo
perché mi hai messo perché non sto
cavalcando che fa pista bagnata stronzo
io te creai e io tedesco si è crepa non
è morto sono quasi morto io in compenso
ok perfetto che ne sa niente non portava
rispetto che doveva bocca da gatto
madonna quante bocche cia cena 3 una da
mucca una daranno una ragazza è bella il
deretano cia il tentacolo del polipo
senza motivo perché attaccato un
lampione puoi vivere vividi ovili che mi
sono messo di tutto impegno per farti
così bello che cosa hai contro di me
questa creatura tua amica perché lei
creata ma se ne sta magna ma che cazzo
dici a voi ragazzi lasciamo perdere
perché sta diventando trash vanno come
se non lo fosse già di suo
cercherò di fare ragazzi il prossimo
episodio online perché anche in
multiplayer sto cazzo di gioco e gli
inter agazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
concluso che gli episodi e cosa che sono
stato momento è un mi piace
e ricordatevi che questo video qua
finirà nelle nelle gallerie d'arte
moderna perché queste creazioni che io
ho fatto verranno proprio esposte voi
siete stati i primi ad assistere alla
creazione di tali opere d'arte ragazzi
ritenetevi fortunatissimi ballo ragazzi
al momento mi piace anche a pacelli
facebook con invito a tornare
descrizione sovvertiti skater ci davano
prossimo video o alle prossime creazioni
strambe va bene